Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture you talked
about computing derivatives
by definition.
And one rule for
computing derivatives
that Professor Jerison
mentioned but didn't prove
was what's called the
constant multiple rule.
So today I want to give
you a proof of that rule
and show you a little bit of
geometric intuition for why
it works.
So the constant
multiple rule says
that if you have a constant c
in a differentiable function, f
of x, that the derivative of
the function c times f of x
is equal to c times the
derivative of f of x.
Just to do a quick example,
suppose that c were 3
and f of x were the
function x squared,
this says that the derivative
d by dx of 3 x squared
is equal to 3 times
the derivative of d
by dx of x squared.
Now, this is good
because we already
have a rule for computing
derivatives of powers of x.
So this says we don't
need a special rule
for computing multiples
of powers of x squared.
We don't need to go back
to the limit definition
to compute the derivative
of 3 x squared.
We can just use the
fact that we know
the derivative of x
squared in order to compute
the derivative of 3 x squared.
So in this case that
would work out to 6x.
In this case.
So it simplifies the number
of different computations
you have to do.
It reduces the number of
times we need to go back
to the limit definition.
So that's the use of the rule.
Let's quickly talk
about its proof.
The idea behind the proof is
you have these two derivatives
and you want to show
that they're equal.
Well, any time you have a
derivative, what it really
means is it's the value of
some limit of some difference
quotient.
So in this case we have the
derivative d by dx of c times f
of x by definition is
the limit of a difference
quotient as delta x goes to 0
of-- so we take the function c
times f of x and we
plug in x plus delta x
and we plug in x and
we take the difference
and we divide by delta x.
So that's c times f of x
plus delta x minus c times
f of x divided by delta x.
Now you'll notice that here
both terms in the numerator
have this constant
factor, c, in them.
So we can factor that out.
And I'll just pull it out in
front of this whole fraction
so that this is
the limit as delta
x goes to 0 of c
times the ratio f of x
plus delta x minus f of x,
all quantity over delta x.
Now, c is just some constant.
This part depends on delta x.
And on x, but on delta x.
So as delta x goes
to zero, this changes
while this stays the same.
What that means is, so
as delta x goes to 0,
this gets closer and
closer to something,
the value of its limit.
And c, you're just
multiplying it in,
so c times-- the limit of c
times this is equal to c times
whatever the limit of this is.
If this is getting closer
and closer to some value,
c times it is getting closer and
closer to c times that value.
So this is equal to
c-- in other words,
we can pull constant
multiples outside of limits.
So this limit as
delta x-- c times
the limit is delta x goes
to 0 of f of x plus delta x
minus f of x over delta x.
And this limit here
is just the definition
of the derivative of f of x.
So this is equal
to, by definition,
c times d by dx of f of x.
So we started with
the derivative
of c times f of x and we
showed this is equal to c
times the derivative of f of x.
That's exactly what we wanted.
So that proves the
constant multiple rule.
We've now proved the
constant multiple rule--
let me talk a little bit
about some geometric intuition
for why this works.
So I've got here, well so, you
know, let's take c equals 2,
just for simplicity.
So here I have a
graph y equals f of x,
and I have also drawn the
graph, y equals 2f of x.
The relationship
between these graphs
is that y equals 2f of x is
what you get when you stretch
the graph for y equals f of x
vertically by a factor of 2.
So, you know, if it
passed through 0 before,
it still passes through 0.
But everywhere else,
if it was above 0,
it's now twice as high.
If it was below 0,
it's now twice as low.
So if you think about what the
definition, what the derivative
means in terms of this
graph geometrically,
it's telling you
the limit-- sorry,
the slope of a tangent line.
Or in other words, the limit
of the slopes of secant lines.
So if you look at
these two curves,
say-- let's pick a
couple values of x, say,
and then maybe x
plus delta x-- so
if you look at the secant
lines for these two curves
through those
points, what you see
is that these two lines,
they have the same you know,
so the slope of a line is
its rise over its run--
so they have the
same run, that we
are talking about the same
little interval, here.
But this, in the function
that's scaled up,
in the y equals
2f of x curve, we
have that that the rise
everything has been stretched
upwards by a factor of
two-- so the rise here is
exactly double the rise here.
So the slope of the secant line
is exactly double the slope
of this secant line.
And similarly,
the tangent line--
just a limit of secant
lines-- has been stretched
by that same factor of two.
So the slope of the
tangent line is exactly
twice the slope of the tangent
line for the other function.
So the tangent line here
is exactly twice as steep
as the tangent line here.
Or in other words, the
derivative of this function
is exactly twice the
derivative of that function.
So that's just a
geometric statement
of this very same
constant multiple rule
that we stated algebraically
at the beginning
and that we just proved.
So that's that.